Joe is with us in Indianapolis hey Joe
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you sir better than I deserve
what's up well in the last couple of
years my wife and I have gotten really
on board with your program we paid off
about 50,000 and that we refinance to
15-year and I'm about 20,000 in our
emergency fund and my question is we're
getting ready to start step four and my
wife's job is pretty much sucking the
life out of her and we're looking at
trying to do something else and should
we start doing the 15% into retirement
or should we just start stockpiling away
to try to prepare for a job because our
incomes about 118 thousand it heard
there's about 75 of that okay what what
would be the chances of her landing a
job that she went to are you talking
about her quitting permanently she wants
to work she doesn't want to be a
stay-at-home mom she wants to work so it
be finding a different job so why not
yet for that while she's still working
there oh we we have we have been and
this it's been kind of tough tough to
find anything right now
well what if you take six or eight
months off because it's tough to find
something that wouldn't be good as yeah
that's oh you leave wave you know how
much you know we have to laugh and we
don't want to either way emergency fund
because she's not happy so we're gonna
see if you gonna stick it out as long as
you can but we're you know trying to
decide if we put off investing into
retirement because we're both there
early 30s and you know we know we need
to tackle that pretty quick so you have
20,000 in your emergency fund you make
118 how much your house payment it's 15
1,500 a month okay all right yeah I
might stop my retirement for a few
months maybe six months and let's see
where we are while we make a job
transition yeah that might not be the
end of the world you could make it up by
dropping it over into a Roth IRA even if
you didn't later he
if you didn't you know if you got behind
on the 401k and couldn't catch up we
could still step back in and do some
Roth's and catch up right yes so um yeah
I think some another $10,000 laying
around wouldn't make me mad okay yeah
that's our that's where we stand and
we're just trying to figure out what the
next step is to move forward yeah what's
the nature what kind of problems are at
her job stress due to what the due to
time that she's there and commute time
and the fact that we have two kids under
three and under and just not being
holding kids three and under are the
kids three and under aren't going to
change yeah we know that but we'd like
her to be home a little more for the
kids so how many what time does she go
in what time she come home it's very a
lot of days a lot of days she'll go in
around nine o'clock she is about an hour
commute so going around nine o'clock and
may not go until 7:00 or 8:00 and
usually the kids are in bed around 8:00
8:30 so she's working 10-hour days 11
our days there everyday okay what would
happen if she sat with her supervisors
and said I'm gonna have to go home on
time that she is the head of her
facility and she's talked to her
superior and they're her responses your
salary to be there as long as you need
to be there yeah um so the facility
closes down if she's not there what
happens if she goes home early then
everything piles up and she you know her
boss kind of looks down on it and my
wife is a perfectionist when it comes to
work so yeah I think so I'm gonna start
working on cutting my hours back let's
shave an hour a day off to start with
and and learn to delegate a little more
and maybe even start talking about the
fact that this facilities understand
left and and because I think some of the
stressor to her work is self-induced now
the commute that's a reason enough to
change for me I'm not driving an hour to
work I Drive seven minutes to work but
uh you could you know you can look at
that but I think some of these things
might be more in her control than we're
acting like this is the Dave Ramsey show
you